welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
Vincent and it's time to celebrate
because Disney's live-action a little
mermaid is here okay across this my
interview with Aquafina and Jacob
Trombley and my 10 fun facts about the
original Little Mermaid I might be
completely out of fish cleanse and
that's not just me being Coy anyway
and he toes the line of being extremely
faithful to the original and making some
big changes that enhance the story and
of course there are a bunch of hidden
details and Easter eggs that we're going
to shed some light on so let's start
clown fishing around and dive into it
the movie opens with some incredible
footage of the raw power of the ocean
but a quote from the original story of
The Little Mermaid by Hans Christian
Anderson breeding but a mermaid has no
tears and therefore she suffers so much
more just your typical happy Disney
intro but director Rob Marshall said
that going back to the source material
of the Hans Christian Anderson version
was one of the first things they did
when deciding how they wanted to
approach a remake and he loved that the
heart of the story was a girl who wanted
to break down the wall between her world
and the surface world and one huge theme
of this movie is how detrimental it is
for people to put up barriers between
each other out of fear misunderstanding
we see time and time again throughout
the movie that both Ariel and Eric are
always striving to tear down those walls
and connect to the other side and it
adds an element of relevance to today's
day and age where it feels like people
are more divided than ever and we see
this theme almost immediately touched on
as the dolphin courses through the water
is just like the beginning of the
animated movie only for the beautiful
moment to be abruptly cut off by a
harpoon being fired at it because the
sailors aboard the ship think it's a
mermaid seeing miss Eric played by Jonah
Howard King leaps down from his work on
the sails to stop them they warn him
that it's the annual Coral Moon that
night when the Sea King calls his
daughters together to lure men to their
deaths using their siren song and Eric
writes us off saying it's just old lore
already showing that he doesn't hold the
same fears and beliefs that others do
this scene ends with Eric accidentally
dropping his Spyglass into the ocean as
the camera dips below the surface and we
transition into Ariel's World once again
we get some of the same beats as the
animated movie as we see blooming an
enemies fish did I say that right
anemone anemone anemone anemone I'm
saying it right we see blooming Anemone
Fish and mermaid swimming through the
waters before arriving at Triton's
Palace where they bonded for a bit more
of a realistic Coral structure that
still glistens a bit with the sunlight
instead of gathering for a royal concert
though the Sailor aboard the ship was
half right as Triton and his daughters
are gathering for the coral moon but in
reality this is to swap up news from the
various seas that the daughters preside
over Triton appears out of thin water
with iridescent armor made of Abalone
shells and a cape consisting of I
believe Peruvian and chavetta fish which
can school together to form shapes in a
really wild way we'll Cruise past
thinking about the life quality of
spending your existence as a cave though
he also blows into a conch shell much
like he does in Greek mythology while an
animated film it seems like all of
Ariel's sisters lived under one roof and
had names beginning and ending with a
this movie gives us a more independent
personalities with all of them ruling
over their own season having unique
names with meanings behind them while
all still ending in a to give them that
familial tie I also love how their
designs seem to be unique to the regions
they hail from and I believe their Tales
are based on real fish as well in The
Little Mermaid guide to merfolk book we
get a ton more information about the
sisters and the lands they preside over
I'll give you the long and short of it
and list what the meanings of their
names are and what fish I believe their
fins might be styled after also my
apologies of my pronunciation for any of
these Seasons off but I'm just taking my
best shot at it since they're all
fictional c's with the one real see that
is mentioned in this movie being during
the song Poor Unfortunate Souls when
Ursula calls upon the Winds of the
Caspian Sea which lies on the border of
Eastern Europe and Central Asia anyway
there's Mala ruler of the chain sea
Karina ruler of the safe sea Indira
ruler of the brine dive sea Perla ruler
of the pitency to make a ruler of the
fracassee caspia ruler of the ethnicity
an aerial meaning Lion of God which
feels a little op who rules over the
Karen AC we then see The Little Mermaid
herself as Ariel played by the amazing
Halle Bailey and flatner voiced by Jacob
Tremblay head to a sunken ship graveyard
to explore Ariel's tale has gotten a
major upgrade in this movie as its range
of colors and shimmery quality provides
an iridescence that's almost like fairy
wings floating through the water as for
flounder in the original animated movie
despite his name suggesting such he is
not a flounder but actually designed
just to look like a general tropical
fish perhaps leaning most closely to a
royal angelfish in this movie however he
appears to be a sergeant major fish with
the same cute little cowlick in a spin
that he had in the animated version as
they explore the ship she find the fork
much like in the movie but first refers
to it as a tiny Trident which is how I
will be referring to all forks from now
on when she brings it to Scuttle voiced
by Aquafina she kindly informs her it's
a dingle hopper in the animated movie
Scuttle is a seagull but in this one
she's a northern Planet which plunged 62
miles per hour into the water when
hunting and stay underwater for about 30
to 45 seconds so in reality this
conversation would have had to go a lot
quicker Ariel is also about to ask about
what true fans know as a snarf lat
before she gets interrupted and has to
leave as she swims off we get the same
intro for Flotsam and Jetsam as in the
original movie where their glowing eyes
combine to transition to Ursula's lair
in this movie Ursula played by Melissa
McCarthy is Triton's younger sister and
Ariel's aunt which was actually the
original plan for the animated movie
before it was eventually scrapped but
was made Canon for the Broadway musical
she doesn't go into a ton of gritty
detail but we learned that she's the
family Pariah banished to Exile for 15
years Ursula's design has elements of
bioluminescence seen in her tentacles
and collar bioluminescence is found in
organisms that live in depths where
light can reach which makes sense as to
why Ariel has to swim so far down to get
to Ursula's Lair it also has a function
in deep sea Predators like anglerfish to
lure unsuspecting victims appropriate
but soon after we get to see the Majesty
of Ariel's Grotto one of the first
things I noticed was she upgraded from a
candelabra to a freaking chandelier nice
girl one cool touch is that when she's
looking at a book asking what a fire is
the picture she's looking at astronomer
by candlelight has an hourglass in the
bottom left corner echoing The Hourglass
in the bottom left-hand corner of the
frame in the shop before this could also
potentially be a callback to the
original movie where Sebastian hits an
hourglass on his way into Ariel's Grotto
one definite callback though is the
iconic shot of Ariel reaching towards
the surface which you just know they had
to include in the remake right after the
song Ariel sees the colorful flashes
from the fireworks and swims to the
surface to investigate right before she
breaches the surface she hits iconic
pose number two from the original
movie's official poster she finds Eric's
ship where they're partying It Up
singing part of the song fathoms below
the opening song in the animated movie
and one of the first songs in the
Broadway show as well the first thing
Ariel sees is them dancing with the help
of their what do you call them it's only
after this that she sees Eric for the
first time and while in the original
movie she pretty much Falls at First
Sight just seeing his face TBH I got it
in this version her first impression of
him is overhearing a conversation
between him and Grimsby where Eric
refuses to take his father's place
trapped inside the castle walls and cut
off from the outside world in this
conversation we learned that Eric wasn't
born into royalty but rather taken in by
the king and queen as a baby when he was
found wash up on ashore after a
shipwreck this is why he feels a
connection to the Sea and wants to
venture out and connect with the world
as he puts it it's in his blood and he
says that while I can't quite explain it
something out there is calling to him
it's this that draws Ariel to Eric
knowing what it's like to feel trapped
by Beauty and wanting more I think
that's a much stronger motivation for
her being drawn to him than just him
being good looking though he is and they
have a lot of things in common in this
movie I'm on our parent who wants to
keep him home to protect them a grotto
that holds all their collections I mean
Eric's even has a skylight just like
Ariel's she also sees his kindness and
willingness us to sacrifice himself when
the ship crashes and he stays aboard the
burning ship to save Max they've added a
cute detail of aerial underwater helping
Max to swim to the Lifeboat which is
likely why he immediately takes to her
when he sees her again as a human once
she saves Eric we're treated to iconic
shots three and four as Eric starts to
come too seeing her silhouetted face and
the waves bursting up around her for the
reprise of part of your world and same
as in the animated version her sitting
on that rock is a nod to The Little
Mermaid statue in Copenhagen Sebastian
played by David Diggs who has worked
with Lyricist lin-manuel Miranda on
several prior projects most notably
Hamilton then traces to his rendition of
under the sea a colorful Feast for the
eyes where you can see real species of
fish like feather stars flatworms and my
personal favorite tortoiseshell Olympics
we then see Eric's castle and I put in
some Orcs trying to place where we were
located in this movie in the original
Little Mermaid Eric's Castle was styled
after the real world Chateau de journal
in Switzerland and while they filmed
this movie in Italy that's almost
certainly not where it's meant to take
place while while the Seas that Triton's
daughters rule over are fictional the
places that Eric lists in the movie
aren't so let's see what we can figure
out when looking at maps with Ariel he
points out the Brazilian Empire which
comprised of Brazil and Uruguay in that
time Venezuela Colombia and the mosquito
Coast before talking about his land he
also found his mermaid statuette on the
coast of Cartagena so we're likely
looking somewhere in the Caribbean and
the music of the village which features
the steel drums heavily backs this up he
also says there's a rainforest and
Lagoon nearby which narrows it down to
possibly somewhere like Jamaica Puerto
Rico or St Lucia but at the beginning of
the movie he says that there's a Spanish
Galleon headed to the mainland to trade
meaning that his Island wasn't owned by
Spain looking at a map of which
countries presided over which Islands at
the time that leaves our safest bet as
Jamaica which was under British rule at
the time which is likely why there are
also some British accents heard on the
island the queen played by Noma domez
wheni serves as a foil to Triton
forbidding Eric to go on any more
voyages because she believes the Sea
Gods are against them and eroding their
land into the ocean But Eric just can't
escape the sea I mean literally they
have a freaking Kyle mural of it right
there in the dining room but this leads
him to sing the new song Wild uncharted
waters which has Ariel's siren song
Motif woven throughout it clear this
song in the background of several more
moments including as he runs up the
staircase to confess his love to Ariel
and when they're about to depart
together at the end of the movie but
while the queen is talking smack about
the Sea Gods try and Ariel sisters are
talking smack about the humans as they
clean the remains of the Shipwreck from
off of a now damaged coral reef and a
misunderstanding about Ariel's mood
eventually leads to Triton finding out
about Eric and discovering her Grotto
it's here that we find out that Ariel's
mother who was also taken with the human
world was killed by a human leading to
Triton forbidding trips to the surface
one difference I like about this scene
is that although the line daddy I love
him in the original movie is iconically
dramatic in this one she just tries to
vouch for Eric by calling him
compassionate and kind which is a little
more down to earth than immediately
declaring love when Triton destroys her
statue of Eric she holds the detached
hand of the statue recreating their
moment on the beach when he grabbed her
hand in this moment of weakness Ursula
appears to Ariel through a magic bubble
that eels make like Glinda in The Wizard
of Oz we just love Bubbles Ursula's
Garden is so much more horrific than in
the original and even tries to choke
Ariel and Ursula's hangout spot is a
giant clam instead of a conch using the
Black Pearl as her crystal ball Ursula
tries to relate to Ariel by saying that
Triton controls everything she sees and
does too and even has a moment that
Echoes Aerials in Poor Unfortunate Souls
when she swims up to the light a few
changes in this portion are that they
remove the verse about it being
preferred on land for ladies not to tuck
the spell requires aerial scale and
blood and an added caveat no matter how
hard she tries she won't remember that
she needs to get a kiss as Ariel
surfaces with her human legs we get
iconic shot number five the hair flip
which Bailey said in an interview took
about 20 takes and her neck was over it
I feel you girl but now the girls got
legs and we got another new song called
for the first time which starts with a
physical gravity Wing Ariel down and
ends with an emotional gravity weighing
her down during this she also discovers
what a fire Iris and Wyatt what's the
word Burns and gets addressed that is a
sea foamy color like her dress in the
Disney parks costume designer Colleen
Atwood said that she made it a point for
the people in the village who live by
the ocean to have a more vibrant color
palette in their costumes and for the
people in the castle to have more
bleached out colors to their garments we
also get another one of my favorite
lines when Scuttle comes in and fully
optimistic asks Sebastian has Ariel
killed the Prince yet kind of
unquestioning support is what I look for
in a friend when Ariel finds Eric's
trinket room while exploring the castle
she picks up his mermaid statuette and
for the first time we get something
close to a titular line as he says my
Little Mermaid causing Anna to go
Ariel also smashes a geode Eric's been
holding on to revealing a crystal
showing that sometimes you have to look
on the inside to find the jam ah
as they're out on the town Jody Benson
the voice of Ariel in the animated film
makes a cameo as a market vendor
offering Ariel a dingle hopper while
saying I think you'll need this it's
they transitioned to the robot scene by
Scuttle stealing Eric's hat so they
chase her to where the rowboat is and to
set the mood instead of singing a
portion of Tchaikovsky's Romeo and
Juliet which Scuttle sings in the
original film she opts for more modern
bounce
they very cleverly rewrite how Eric is
able to guess Ariel's Name by having
Ariel point to the Aries constellation
to get Eric to say it and then she moves
his lips get him to say an l sound
honestly it makes more sense than
pulling the name Ariel out of thin air
I'll take it but Ursula knows this
spells trouble and opts to turn herself
into a human using a long-shaped potion
to do so meanwhile torn between
continuing the search for The Voice he's
looking for and pursuing Ariel Eric runs
the sand from the spot on the beach
where he was saved through his hand
while contemplating when he finally
decides to tell Ariel his feelings he
follows the symbolic and literal light
towards the palace only to hear Vanessa
Ursula's human form singing the siren
song when he finds her there's a glow in
his eyes that matches the nautilus shell
necklace's glow just like in the
animated version showing he has been
Bewitched were then treated to one of my
personal favorite new songs scuttlebutt
which plays on scuttle's trait of
rambling and getting off track with
ranty lyrics that sometimes spill over
the musical bar at the suggestion that
Eric might be proposing that day Ariel
runs out to find him with Vanessa who
wears a purple gown and has black nail
polish to fit Ursula's color scheme
Ariel runs off and laments on the same
rock that she sang the part of your
world reprise this time singing what did
I give to live Where You Are break it
Scuttle alerts her of what Ursula has
done however and she makes her way back
to the castle where Eric is introducing
Vanessa to the court the queen donning a
hair accessory that resembles Coral
gives Eric her mother's ring which looks
to be a blue topaz blue topaz often
represents Clarity communication and
it's said that those who wear the
gemstones should embrace their authentic
selves hint Eric Ariel makes it to the
castle and reveals Ursula but not before
the sun goes down and is too late as
King Triton sacrifices his Triton and
Crown to save Ariel Ursula gets the
recognizable Crown from the animated
movie which in this is made from shark's
teeth an epic battle begins with Ariel
and Eric coming out on top but are still
separated as Ariel's back in her mermaid
form the barrier between their worlds
re-established but Sebastian finally
stands up to the king arguing that he
hasn't done everything in his power to
make her happy and Triton decides to
change her into a human and let her live
the life she wants reunited Eric and
Ariel decide to set sail and explore
uncharted waters Ariel now in a white
dress with pink accents that pays homage
to both her wedding press and pink dress
in the original film the queen says that
their marriage marks A New Beginning for
them perhaps a nod to the movie Ariel's
beginning and Ariel and Eric's set off
but not before Ariel thanks her father
for hearing her to which she responds
you shouldn't have had to give up your
voice to be heard seeing the merfolk and
humans United Ariel sheds a tear of Joy
hearkening back to the quote from the
beginning of the movie the film comes to
a close the same way the animated one
does with the two worlds United to send
Ariel and Eric off with a part of your
world Motif playing in the background as
they sail off into the sunset beautiful
and now all that's left is to see if
there's a sequel waiting in the wings
and also if you haven't be sure to check
out my interview with Aquafina and Jacob
it was a great time and they had some
really fun in photo share until then you
can follow me on Twitter at atanavanston
and follow subscribe to new rockstars at
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love see you later
[Music]